what is your opinion
on humans and how long we're going to be
here on earth do you think we're ever
going to have to leave earth
oh yeah definitely currently all our
eggs are in one basket
and everything that is precious to us
could get eliminated extinct uh
if something catastrophic happens on
earth uh
if an asteroid impacts us or if there is
a
uh for example um a nuclear war
or a climate change or something
catastrophic
um and it would make much more sense to
spread our eggs
in different baskets and go somewhere
else as well
and have duplicates of what we hold
important and valuable here it's sort of
like um
the gutenberg printing press you know
the
there were very few copies of the bible
before the printing press
was invented then they were all hand
written
and each of them was extremely precious
but once the printing press came to
exist
there were many more copies and if
something bad happened to one of them
it wasn't a catastrophe you could make
new ones
and we can imagine saving life as we
know it on earth
and the approach would be similar to
what noah did you know in the biblical
story of knox arc
there is uh the story about the great
flood that endangered
life on earth and so noah decided to
build an ark
and put animals in it so that it will
save them
uh we can in principle design a similar
approach and build
knock spaceship that will save life on
earth
but we don't need to put elephants and
you know whales on it uh we just need to
put a computer and a 3d printer
and if the computer has the information
about the dna of four life
forms that that we care about then
this system can go to another planet and
in principle it could make
the life as we know it out of the raw
materials
that exist there on another planet you
don't need to bring
the life with you you can recreate them
as long as we figure out how to make
synthetic life
you know and that's not um
speculative because people are as we
speak people are trying to produce
synthetic life in the laboratory
and so i won't be surprised if we if
within the next
few decades we will be able to do that
and so once we are able to do that
we can potentially produce life on other
planets without carrying it
from from earth and and just you know
using what we know about the genetics
and
and so forth in making that life over
there out of the raw materials there
how long do you think it would be before
we would have to do that
oh that depends on us how quickly we
inflict the wounds on ourselves you know
if
if we are not smart enough we might not
survive for more than a few centuries
from now
uh we started developing our
technologies about a century ago
and our technologies are advancing
with exponentially with a characteristic
time scale of a few years
so it's quite possible that within the
next century
you know we unless we are careful we
could develop technologies that will
destroy us
and then you know we need to be really
careful about what we do to the planet
what we do to ourselves
we don't pay that much attention to it
because we are
so close to when technology started
developing but once we go a few decades
into the future we will be in a real
risk of extinction i think and
because there would be technologies that
could potentially
destroy life on the planet and then
we just need to be smart enough to avoid
that and
right now i wouldn't say that we are
very intelligent in the way
we do our politics um uh there are lots
of conflicts and
we invest most of our efforts in
fighting
uh each other you know among nations
and so forth and um that is not
the smart approach we should collaborate
especially on issues that science can
address
you know and you could see that in the
context of covid right so
when it started in china there wasn't
much sharing of information that was
and science is global science is
international
it's supposed to be a mode of
collaboration among nations and
in promoting a better future for
humanity
and i very much hope that then
ultimately
science will prevail and suppress all
these
tensions among people that really
could bring us down you know if if you
look at the world wars
uh there was a lot of effort dedicated
to killing people and that makes no
sense whatsoever
yeah i think especially recently i feel
like the internet has
really made everything in this world so
much more transparent and i think it's
it's really there's a a big paradigm
shift happening
especially with the recent news i'm sure
you've heard the uh
gamestop stocks the people online that
were buying the stocks the hedge funds
bet against and
10 years ago this is something no one
understood
hedge funds or the stock market or or
what these bets on them failing even
were
um and people were able to
benefit off that and essentially create
this massive gap
this massive gap between the
billionaires on wall street and the
average
the average working person blue collar
worker
and and now it's becoming the internet
has made this
so much more transparent i feel like
this is something that has to happen
with science that's
you know you can somehow correlate it to
what's happening with what you're doing
and now you released your book and
you're talking to everybody about
it well one thing i would like to
highlight in this context is
we tend to think that technology and
science
is superior to the humanities you know
so humanities are in decline
the study of philosophies the study of
literature and so forth
young people are more attracted to
science and technology
the problem is that we develop
tools using science and technology that
could destroy us
and the only way to prevent it is to
have the humanists
telling us how to guide
ourselves towards a better future you
know how to for example
how to set the rules such that genetic
engineering
will not end up making you know people
the type that we want and all kinds of
other
issues that come up like artificial
intelligence you know if we
allow it to make life death decisions
uh on medical issues
we have to worry about the morality of
that and
you know at what level do we allow the
machine to decide the fate of a person
versus having people involved you know
in the past it was the doctor that made
the decision and
you could trust the doctor better
because the doctor would be a human that
that has a bigger perspective that
is more balanced in a way but if you
have a machine deciding you have to
decide about a set of rules of what's
moral and what's what's ethical and
how the machine decides who dies and who
lives you know
and there are lots of such issues with
modern technologies and
the humanities the way i see it play a
central role
and you know i as a young kid i was
mostly interested in philosophy
i grew up on a farm and then
circumstances brought me into physics
and astrophysics but i
value these areas of humanities like
philosophy
very much i think they are essential for
guiding us to a better future without
them
uh we could be nerds developing all
kinds of tools that will kill us as
a civilization
i